this drum beat right here changed hip
hop forever
[Music]
not just hip-hop but it changed pop rock
and dance music too
[Music]
the drum break from funky drummer by
James Brown has been the basis for songs
across genre making it one of the most
popular samples of all time but there
are millions of drum beats to sample out
there so we want to know why do so many
artists choose this one
[Music]
in fact when it was released in 1970
funky drummer didn't even crack the top
50 charts it wasn't until 15 years later
that the drum beat started appearing in
hundreds of songs so was it all a
coincidence or was Clyde stubblefield's
drumming just that good this story is
about how a 20 second drum loot became
one of the most popular sounds in music
history
Ella and I are going to take what we've
learned and make our own song using the
funky drummer beat but before we do that
we want to discover what made this beat
so special in the first place as
Questlove said in the 2011 interview
funky drummer has done miracles for
hip-hop adding when you talk about the
most perfect beat it's not even that
funky drummer wins in a technical aspect
but in an artistic aspect it's hands
down the most perfect beat you can Loop
everyone I know as a producer that's
gotten their start in hip-hop production
they all have their story about the
first time they heard funky Drummond
[Music]
the story of funky drummer starts with
the funky drummer himself the late Clyde
Stubblefield born in Chattanooga
Tennessee the self-taught Stubblefield
served as Brown's drummer from 1965 to
1971 and appeared on tracks like cold
sweat Say It Loud I'm Black and I'm
Proud and of course funky drummer to
learn more about Clyde's double field I
talked to Joey B Banks a drummer from
Madison Wisconsin who was mentored by
Stubblefield himself how did you meet
Clyde Stubblefield when I was uh 15
years old I started hanging out and
doing local Jam sessions in the Madison
area I just sat in and jammed and he was
there and he approached me and uh he's
like you got it you got it man you got
it you keep going you keep doing what
you're doing you you know he always from
that point on in my life he was just
kind of an advocate you know for a young
black drummer you know because it was
only like two of us in the whole city of
Madison what made Clyde's double feel so
special as a drummer and what should
people remember about his drumming I
think his biggest influence obviously
was the originality of his music I mean
his beat his beat was like before him
nobody had ever heard anything like
like his beat
um and I think his pocket which is
unparalleled is is just you know most of
the recordings you hear with James Brown
there's no we're not using click tracks
he's just it's just solid on the mark
everybody he would come in lay down his
drum tracks the band would come in and
lay down their track after that's how
Clyde worked
funky drummer was made on November 20th
1969 at Cincinnati's King Studios
towards the end of an exhausting tour
Clyde Summerfield was only 18 at the
time and said his part was something he
put together to just pass time away in
fact even as the beat grew in popularity
Stubblefield wasn't the biggest fan he
described it in a 1994 interview as
boring really boring and so simple so
blah still the 20 second solo toward the
end of funky drummer would be
immortalized for decades to come but why
to understand how funky drummer became
so popular we need to talk about the
beginnings of hip-hop music
thank you
it all started in New York City during
the 1970s specifically in the South
Bronx where people got together at block
parties to listen to music and dance and
the music was led by an emcee on the mic
and a DJ on the turntables DJs like cool
herc and Grandmaster Flash would play
funkin Soul records for the crowd they
quickly learned that the drum breaks
were the most danceable parts of a song
so they innovated by playing the same
record on two turntables that way the DJ
could rewind one record while the other
played to create an infinite drum Loop
[Music]
DJs began Craig digging for Funk and
soul records with danceable drum loops
and because the loops were instrumental
it gave space for MCS to wrap on top of
the beat when hip-hop artists began
recording their own songs this practice
continued and sampling became one of the
foundations of hip-hop music to get a
better understanding I sat down with
Bandy c a djn producer from New York
City who got his start during the 1980s
the original hip-hop producers most were
DJ
and that is because the DJ knew how to
control the crowd music so I think from
a DJ side if I'm looking at the music to
make a b
I'm I'm listening to the track but I'm
not just listening to the beat I'm
listening to maybe the guitar I'm
listening to other parts because that
sampling came in we might take the the
Beat from this the the the shout James
Brown said from the very beginning the
the guitar riff as we listen go all that
riff and then we'll pull that riff out
and then you know and then you're just
basically making this gumbo of of what
your creativity will offer and um and
then you put it together James Brown
knew that artists were looking for drum
bricks to sample and in 1986 he released
the compilation album of his old tracks
called in the jungle Groove on the first
side of the record was funky drummer and
on side two was the funky drummer drum
solo looped for three minutes this
changed everything and the Funky drummer
break became a go-to for hip-hop
producers looking for a steady Groove
when
how did you find it I found it the way
that almost
DJs found
beats and that is in a parrots record
stack
that's how it started if anybody tells
you anything else they're lying by the
end of the 90s the drum break had been
sampled by artists in other genres too
like Sinead O'Connor
and George Michael
[Music]
Montgomery became a popular tool for
artists making break beat dance music
producers would speed up the break like
in this song by Aphex Twin
theme song for The Powerpuff Girls
it's important to mention that some
people mix up funky drummer with another
popular drum sample called the amen
break that break comes from the 1969
track Amen Brother by the Soul band The
Winston
[Music]
both breaks were featured in the
compilation album Ultimate Breaks and
Beats when sped up in some dance music
tracks the two breaks can sound similar
why using funky drummer specifically
became so popular from like a Beat lead
sample standpoint funky drawing works
because of the way he's using the space
it's not a whole bunch of drums going on
and not a bunch of parts going on but
the ghost notes
the Ghost Notes add so much flavor
to whatever is happening you know it's
like that special little seasoning on
top or you know it's the sprinkles or
still whatever that just that it's the
Emeril Lagasse bam right
I want to break down what makes this
solo what it is first the left hand
Quest love said in an interview
Stubblefield has a marksman's left hand
unlike any other drummer in the 20th
century adding the thing that defines
him that sets him apart from other
drummers are his grace notes which are
sort of like the condiments of what
spices up the main focus the main focus
is the snare hits on two and four the
ghost notes are played in between those
main hits on 204. he's a Groove without
any Ghost Notes
[Music]
now here's the Groove With The Ghost
Notes
[Music]
the thing about the beat is that it's
bare hi-hat
kick
snare that's all he's playing
that open space is why so many artists
have sampled it because it offers so
much room to play around with third and
lastly his repetition he doesn't deviate
from the pattern and maintains it for
eight bars following the instructions
Brown gave them
[Music]
what do you think made Clyde
stubblefield's drumming like a really
good match for hip-hop as much as Clyde
made hip hop hip-hop made claw if that
makes sense in terms of the time because
what happened in my estimation is
had it not have been for the grassroot
DJs pursuing Beats
his transcended the regular beats so all
of a sudden it was like the cheat code
to move a crowd if it hit his beat you
know what I mean so funky drama became
bigger than just the beat itself it
became like this movement
according to Who sampled funky drummer
has been sampled over 1 700 times but
even though Clyde Stubblefield laid the
groundwork for all of this music he
didn't get the credit he deserved the
reality is he never saw any royalties
from the songs that sampled his drum
part because he wasn't credited as a
songwriter James Brown was although
Stubblefield tried to capitalize on his
Resurgence in hip-hop with solo albums
like the Revenge of the funky drummer he
would never be able to truly live off
the success of his beloved drum break
but that doesn't mean that artists
influenced by Stubblefield and his work
didn't look out for him where they could
shortly after Prince passed away in 2016
it was revealed that the Purple Rain
icon paid about eighty thousand dollars
in the drummers costs as Stubblefield
had survived cancer in 2000 and coped
with kidney diseases since 2002. What
mattered mostest double field wasn't the
money but being credited and recognized
for his work I'm the world sample's
number one selfless drummer so hey I
haven't got a penny for it yet though
but me dude is super humble super kind
loved everybody signed us autographs
Cloud Stubblefield peace of love I mean
he's he was he was just a genuinely good
guy and and in some ways good to a false
although Stubblefield passed away from
kidney failure in 2017. his legacy as a
drummer still lives on with funky
drummer continuing to be an integral
part of that the drum break still gets
sampled with everyone from Nicki Minaj
to Ed Sheeran's shirt sleeves using
stubblefield's drum part
under your eyes
there's even a documentary in the works
about stubblefield's impact called give
the drummer some which he was able to be
a part of before he passed in 2011
Stubblefield got on stage with Chuck D
and The Roots to perform fight the power
on The Late Night show and epic method
the cover
normally Chuck V would wrap over a
sample but that night he had the real
funky drummer by his side
foreign
now that we've learned about funky
drummer LA and I are going to attempt to
make our own song inspired by the funky
drummer sample okay this is the approach
that I would take I feel like we could
totally take like do you listen to Pink
Panthers or do you know who she is
okay Pink Panthers is like this she flew
up on Tick Tock she's like a UK drum and
based pop girly she's very talented
she's like songwriter
um and has a very gentle floaty voice
[Music]
want to do a
funky drummer slash Pink panther-ish
Pink Panthers uh Slash house type
[Music]
without stubble feel it's safe to say
that hip-hop wouldn't be what it is
[Music]
his drumming provided the foundation for
a genre that still continues to borrow
from him and even though he never truly
had the chance to reap the reward of
that there's no denying the mark he left
behind
before you go I want to let you know
about fight the power how hip-hop
changed the world a new PBS series
hosted by hip hop Legend chutti it's
about how hip-hop became a global
movement that spoke truth to power check
out the link in the description below
and let them know soundfield sent you
[Music]